how are you i'm doing well rachel with
e.t how are you you look stunning well
thanks i mean i'm doing like a oh we're
like in we're like we're like in the
same collection kind of that's a thing
that people say about fashion right
you're like off the runway i'm like
street style ready to wear yes
yes all the words the fashion words that
i definitely know look girl you do know
how to make an entrance or rather should
i say you don't know how to make an exit
the whole elevator's that one cause you
never know when you're gonna get stuck
in an elevator just vibing in this
elevator
we love it
it was a very dramatic it was so funny
the second that the elevator like
clunked it was like well
obviously we're not trapped in this
elevator that would be too crazy that
would be insane so like immediately i
was like it was like i was in this
absurdist comedy thank goodness because
otherwise i would have been in a horror
film about being trapped in an elevator
and you're already in a thriller so you
don't need two but i was just like
cracking jokes god i am annoying i was
but you know you get nervous because
you're trapped in an elevator with seven
people you gotta make light of the
situation and thank goodness you had an
elevator exit emergency exit appropriate
dress on oh yeah no i i truly like
everest for the occasional hat was like
a mini skirt and i was like something
tells me that today is going to be the
day to wear like the long flowy skirt
and that was the day that i had to climb
out of a hatch at the top of an elevator
it was the right call
i'm just saying you know i've seen the
post on it on the gram you had some
dashing firemen there they weren't too
shabby
and i'm sure that their wives or
girlfriends are wonderful as well
because i don't know
so i will say well done to all of you
yes i do want to get to your film though
obviously we're glad you're safe and
you're here on the carpet you're no
stranger to tiff obviously but what is
it like being a parts you're you're the
lead in this exciting film that is
already getting so much buzz for your
performance
[Music]
alex please please go away please go
away please go away
i'm blown away that we get to premiere
at tiff i love tiff i love coming here
but you know we shot this movie in
toronto and you know in
further up into beautiful parts of
ontario so i feel really grateful um to
be back here and showing it for the
first time i cannot wait to see this
this just seems like a mind spin that is
kind of relatable sadly um and you are
guiding us through this thrilling
journey yeah it's a very like it's a
very tense film very anxious film and um
i felt uh like it was a really safe
environment
uh that was created on set for everybody
to do their best work and i'm just
really grateful that um
people are going to finally see it
finally and finally to wrap things up
10-year anniversary of pitch perfect
this can you believe it no but i am i'm
like obsessed and i love the friendships
that you've created from being a part of
this it's really obnoxiously like
adorable because we because we will tech
we are texting each other exactly what
you think we're texting each other i
believe it's been 10 years you guys are
my family i'm so grateful like it's like
are we do we think someone's watching
like that's how much it feels like i
can't believe these relationships are
what everybody sort of imagines that
they are it's like i'm so lucky to have
those girls in my life we need like a
round table or behind the scenes film of
the pitch perfect gals in real life
action um i think we do a little more
drinking and dancing than we need to put
on camera and you know you can always
yes
[Music]